all right thank you busy night and
tonight on Hannity thank you for joining
us now the president tonight once again
taking bold action to secure the
American people sad when you really stop
and think this is about lives isn't it
our fellow Americans seriousness
involved in this you wouldn't know it
from the media Democrats now the one guy
that was ahead of the curve as it
relates to China travel bans the need to
secure America's borders is now taking
another important measure to protect we
the American people and our jobs take a
look we have a solemn duty to ensure
these unemployed Americans regain their
jobs and their livelihoods therefore in
order to protect American workers I will
be issuing a temporary suspension of
immigration into the United States you
heard about that last night by pausing
immigration will help put unemployed
Americans first in line for jobs as
America reopens so important it would be
wrong and unjust for Americans laid off
by the virus to be replaced with new
immigrant labor flown in from abroad now
certain essential workers will
reportedly be exempt from the
immigration suspension that would
include doctors on the front lines
battling koban 19 other health workers
and Americans we always welcome
immigrants but the president's right to
secure our borders why we need to vet
people make sure that they don't have
radical ties we have to make sure now
people are healthy not to be invasive to
make sure they're healthy to protect the
American people they have to be able to
provide for themselves and yeah 90% of
America's heroin crosses that border we
need to do it for that reason as well
then by the way welcome to our great
American family the 60-day suspension
will give us time to assess our economy
give Americans time to get back to work
hopefully sooner than later what we have
now witnessed in the past several months
the media mob will never tell you
Democrats will never acknowledge it is
unprecedented and so is this
administration's response we are now
witnessing right before our very eyes
what has been and is the greatest
medical mobilization this country has
ever seen
for as
Trump vowed to get States all the
critical supplies the resources they
need so many states most states most
governors were not prepared for anything
no emergency he's delivered in the
promise in a big way and so far the
federal government has distributed fifty
seven point four million and 95 masks
and they're being built as we speak
eighty five point three million surgical
masks 6.4 million face shields twelve
point three million surgical gowns six
hundred and thirty eight million sets of
gloves nearly 11,000 respirators the
strategic stockpile still has what
nearly 10,000 ventilators and storage
that number is surging the GM assembly
line is now working and they are
producing every day over the next week
more than 500 will be delivered as
promised we had thousands more than we
ever needed tens of thousands more will
soon be on the way the president and his
team triggering the defense production
Act worked and thanks to all these great
American businesses by the way they
never stopped working they kept
supplying our hospitals our heroes on
the front line our doctors our nurses
our janitors and hospitals the real
heroes here well they were being
supported by people that didn't stop
working just like the food was going on
the shelves and the medicines were in
your pharmacies even in states like New
York they all stepped up to the plate
they never stopped working they never
shut down farmers farmed Packers packed
truckers truck and thank God
those would stock those shelves and they
stayed stock meanwhile the United States
also leading the world on testing no
country even close is tested more of its
citizens than any other country many
countries combined as a matter of fact
the president mobilized our great
military over 5,500 US military
personnel they have been deployed across
two dozen hospitals twenty-eight
thousand seven hundred National Guard
heroes they are now on duty as well by
the way the Javits Center that personnel
came from the president same with the
comfort that personnel came from the
president let's not forget about project
air bridge that's the public-private
partnership was organized by the White
House
it said massive US cargo planes to pick
up crucial medical supplies from
factories around the world and get him
here as fast as possible so far
sixty-four flights have been completed
at least 50 more are scheduled this
massive mobilization did not happen
overnight didn't happen by chance either
from the very first days of the virus
the president has taken one bold action
after another to protect American lives
there's an op-ed in the Wall Street
Journal rightly pointed out President
Trump
acted with dispatch to keep Americans
safe even when it was unpopular like on
January 31st when President Trump banned
travel to and from China then the first
quarantine in over 50 years then
subsequent travel bans the mob the media
raced to call him racist
they said he overreacted the New York
Times geniuses that they are they
indicated days later perfectly safe to
travel to China hmm I wonder if anyone
followed the New York Times horrific
advice mmm quiring minds want to know
the more confused than ever Joe Biden
called the president xenophobic
hysterical accused of a fear mongering
all the while Democrats what were they
doing on Capitol Hill they were consumed
by their impeachment stunts they weren't
focused on the corona virus just
criticizing the travel ban days earlier
Nancy Pelosi remember she was signing
and handing out those commemorative
impeachment pens and taking selfies on
February 4th during the president's
State of the Union address yep as he was
talking about the corona virus she was
busy with another political stunt pre
ripping and then officially ripping up
the speech pre-planned temper tantrum
for the cameras February 24th that
genius that loves ice cream she went
down to the crowded streets of San
Francisco's Chinatown couraged everyone
to come visit March the left was totally
preoccupied with their insane political
narrative that the president was racist
for calling the coronavirus Wuhan or the
China coronavirus even though the virus
originated in Wuhan in China remember
this we are not behaving well when we
talk about as the President does every
day
the Chinese virus the Wuhan flu and all
of these races
description using this this is a virus
that came from the territory of China
but came from bats
this is a bat virus not a China virus it
doesn't speak Chinese
the president says no this is not racist
at all what of course it's naked ly
racist and obviously racist and
blatantly racist for the President to
call it a Chinese virus or a foreign
virus that is just not it's just so
dangerous that while the mob in the
media spent March using the virus as a
political weapon which they did other
top Democrats they were still playing
down the severity of the pandemic now
comrade de Blasio March the second he
was encouraging New Yorkers to go out on
the town catch a play the governor he
claimed the disease wouldn't be as bad
in New York as other countries wrong on
both parts New York is an international
City New York City is more densely
populated than any other place in
America geographically the smallest with
the highest concentration of people far
more risk for a terrorist attack and
viral outbreaks than anyone else in the
country yet the city of New York was
woefully unprepared in fact sometime
after 2016
comrade de Blasio they're ever
complaining mayor actually auctioned off
the city's 500 reserve ventilators but
he doesn't know who got them and the
city's stockpile of PPE supplies well
they were virtually non-existent so when
the virus exploded which was predictable
because they had multiple studies
including the city of New York the
federal government came to the rescue
and rightfully so it was the president
he ordered the construction of numerous
emergency hospitals in and around New
York he staffed them for the mayor with
federal personnel he sent the USNS
comfort to New York Harbor he staffed it
with his personnel you ordered the Army
Corps of Engineers FEMA to construct a
massive the largest in the country
temporary hospital at the Javits Center
and he ordered both the ship and the
Javits Center to be converted to accept
Kovac patients not an easy thing to do
you got to change the ventilation
everything else they got it done and the
president also sent all the ventilators
and
millions of medical supplies and
medicine that de Blasio never had but
comrade de Blasio not particularly
grateful shamefully standing in front of
a microphone accusing the president of
leaving New Yorkers to die can't make
this up he said it watch I remember
famously in the 1970s when one of your
predecessors Gerald Ford didn't care to
help New York City during the fiscal
crisis there was that famous Daily News
cover that said Ford to Citi drop dead
so my question is mr. Trump mr.
president are you going to save New York
City are you telling New York City to
drop dead comrade de Blasio if President
Trump didn't bail you're sorry
unprepared ass out guess what
many more New Yorkers in your city would
have died many more would have been
infected many more would have been
hospitalized and nobody would have had a
ventilator
instead New York City thanks to
President Trump you can thank him mr.
mayor and seeing thankfully a
precipitous decline in hospitalizations
intubations a death rate not fast enough
but it's also declining comrade de
Blasio he should be thanking the
president because he built a man the
hospital's for you mr. mayor he sent you
the ventilators you sold he sent you the
medical equipment you never had knowing
that the threats were real for New York
now you should be held accountable for
your complete ineptitude incompetence
and frankly your kind of ungrateful too
because the American taxpayers we're
paying for all of that that means people
outside of New York
you can thank them too this brings us to
something we've never we've got to
noticed over the past several weeks now
while the president faces a hostile
press corps every single solitary second
of every day now by the way Governor
Cuomo met with the president of New York
president the governor to his credit has
consistently praised the president if
few minor hiccups here and there but to
his credit the governor's been thankful
the governor of New York has worked with
the president daily but we have noticed
the liberal media mob does treat him
differently than President
he faces a far less hostile mob in the
media a quick example is it possible
that your impulse to put a positive spin
on things may be giving Americans a
false any and where is dr. pouchy
I don't know but every time you ask that
question whenever he's not here look you
say where is he and you'll say is there
a problem
responsibility and action today we hit
the Grimm milestone of more than 40,000
Americans now having died from the
corona virus can you explain then why
you come out here and you are reading
clips and and and showing clips of prays
for you and for your administration well
you just saw it's not shocking and I
don't blame Governor Cuomo but I do
blame the mob and the media there's the
same people frankly they've been many
that have been rooting since Donald
Trump became president that he fell from
day one the same mob that lied smeared
slandered besmirched one conspiracy
theory hoax after another you know they
can't acknowledge a single good thing
the president has done people should ask
the mob and the media hey in retrospect
was the president's travel ban a good
thing did the president do a good job
building those hospitals for New York
and the president do a good job of
getting the ventilators built and all
the medical supply sent to the
ill-prepared mayor of New York even
during a national emergency the Bob
never changes they will even politicize
a virus because they so hate Donald
Trump that's how sick they are but
meanwhile we have their timeline March
8th fake news CNN it's Trump's Katrina
yeah in the middle of Trump getting the
supplies together
March 9th Washington Post this is Eric
pimples paper calling at Donald Trump's
Chernobyl March 12th when President
Trump extended the travel ban to Europe
the mob slammed him for infecting
international relations
March 13th when the president declared
emergency Time magazine called it an
omission of failure
March 19 fake News CNN claiming Trump's
lack of imagination was costing American
lives and treasurer March 30th Oh the
Boston Globe not to be undone by anyone
else in the mob accusing the president
of having blood on his hands April 8th
the psychos over at MSDN see that live
in that whole altered universe of theirs
well they had one of their paid
commentators and host saying that tens
of thousands of people will die because
of trump's coronavirus incompetence
April 11 New York Times very same paper
encouraging Americans to travel to China
after the travel ban thumb that they are
they wrote the Trump should have seen
the virus coming he did the band ten
days after the first case you six days
later would tell them people it's safe
to travel to China
yikes Monday very angry MSDN see by the
way former McCain for president liberal
Steve Schmidt totally lost his mind
Steve what's happened to you
take a look more than 40,000 Americans
are dead this didn't have to be so it's
so because of the inaptitude of the
White House response four years on from
the promise of Oh make America great
again and I alone can fix it we can
survey now the wreckage and the
magnitude of the disaster in this
country that has been wrought by the
Trump presidency the inaptitude of the
federal government shows everybody
around the world from a lie to adversary
what a clown show American governance
has become it's sad predictable this
kind of rhetoric really in the middle of
a national emergency it has real
consequences the mob and the media
they're breathless effort from day one
of the presidency of Donald Trump
literally make him into a villain why
smear slander hoax conspiracy they did
it all they're totally letting the
world's worst bad actor get off the hook
this virus started in Wuhan China the
Chinese government attempted to cover it
up they lie to the world they killed
scientists murdered doctors and
oppressed important data that the world
needed they shut down all domestic
travel to and from Wuhan within China
but they kept international flights
going protecting themselves infecting
the world they should pay